[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let me get to steve palazzolo once we
figured out how to pronounce his name
we'd love to have him on co-host a pro
football focus nfl podcast do you want
to jump in on any of those topics we've
already had
well i mean the brady bledsoe thing i
mean clearly that's the most impactful
injury um i think the blind side's
overrated because when the quarterback
looks to his
left his blind side's protected by the
right tackle so i think it's overrated
um and then uh brisette could have some
success this weekend because the miami's
got some good playmakers but their
offensive line is rough so i would go
justin fields there and once again what
you offer what pro football focus offers
is not opinions it's all numbers based
yeah correct yeah and there's
interpretation anytime you get a number
there's interpretation there's context
but yeah it's it's it's
a quantified film study is what we do
that's how we come up with our grades
all right
tom brady versus the rams defense you
have two of the top five defenders in
the game i'm guessing maybe the best at
their individual positions and aaron
donald and jaylen ramsey how does tom
brady and the buccaneers attack the rams
this weekend
it's a tough one i mean it's going to
look a lot different than what the bucks
faced the first two weeks against the
cowboys and the falcons the rams defense
my big question coming in was they lose
brandon staley who was really forward
thinking and taking away the deep ball
and playing the pass before the run and
all these different things that he did
last year and they're carrying that over
jalen ramsey's playing remember late
career charles woodson when he was out
there kind of playing a little
linebacker and in the slot i mean that's
how jalen ramsay's playing in and around
the line of scrimmage blowing things up
so the bucks have to spread them out be
patient in the underneath game but the
rams match up really well and they gave
the bucks trouble last year on monday
night football that was one of the few
games where the bucks offense was not
very good so it's a it's a great matchup
antonio brown might be out but the bucks
look like right now when when all those
guys are out there all those receivers
and gronk and uh cameron breit those
tight ends really tough to cover because
brady just goes who's the open man this
week so i think it'll be a good bat the
rams will do the best job against the
bucks offense the bucks will still find
a way to score some points though more
likely to happen ramsay gets an
interception from brady or aaron
donald's sacks brady
i'll definitely go aaron donald sack i
mean he's
he's gonna he wins you know about 20 25
of his pass rushes which is incredible
for an interior defensive lineman uh you
know most guys are 10 12 you know maybe
15. so donald will he's got a much
better shot i think of getting a sack
and brady's brady's smart he doesn't
have to throw at jalen ramsey he can
avoid him as needed
chargers and the chiefs
i've mentioned this a couple times it
feels like if you're going to beat the
chiefs at least in the afc got to be
able to run the football baltimore can
run it cleveland can run it um who else
am i leaving uh the titans can run it
can the chargers run it is that is that
the approach to beat the chiefs if you
were the chargers i think it depends on
the type of team you have i think if you
are the ravens or the browns and that is
one of your strengths that's a piece i
think what the chargers have showed is
they could put the ball in justin
herbert's hands and they haven't scored
a ton of points but he's been pretty
efficient a couple mistakes against the
cowboys but he's really good in that
washington game in week one had all
those third down conversions i think you
have to score points against the chiefs
that's the key what the browns did in
week one is they maximized every
opportunity fourth and three and instead
of kicking a field goal they're going
for it you have to say i have to score
30 and then hope that we can keep them
to under 30 and you know the ravens
pretty much did that right so um i think
you got to score as many points as
possible and from the chargers
standpoint that's justin herbert
throwing to keenan allen throwing to
mike williams and then figuring out how
austin eckler is a part of the run game
and catching the ball out of the
backfield have you graded out justin
herbert and matthew stafford the first
two weeks
yeah stafford's one of our highest
graded quarterbacks herbert you know
he's he's 11th right now in our in our
grades uh was to stafford's third um so
stafford has been
a little bit better than his career
baseline and and probably shown hey look
this rams offense is a nice little mesh
with his skill set and they've tapped
into
the downfield passing attack a little
bit more with the rams
what's the grade for jimmy garoppolo so
far
he's one of those guys one of my
favorite things to do is to take pff
passing grade and compare it to say pass
a rating or yards per your traditional
stats in garoppolo is let's see where he
ranks he's down there oh gosh where is
he
he's too low 24th he's 24th in our
grades passer rating he's top 10. so
when you see guys that are lower in our
numbers higher in passer rating or
traditional stats you generally
attribute that to luck or kyle shanahan
being great the playmakers being great
debo samuels catching a jump ball and
running 70 yards for a touchdown so
that's been the garoppolo story he
missed a lot of throws in that eagles
game and was one of the reasons why they
only scored 17 points even though they
won but what are you factoring in that
the qbr is not factoring in
so we're looking at the quality of every
single throw so again if you know if
garoppolo
throws a jump ball and it legitimately
should be tipped away or whatever it is
and the receiver wins at the catch point
and then if especially if the receiver
wins at the catch point and then runs
another 50 yards for a touchdown that's
a whole bunch of credit that's going to
the quarterback that he didn't really
earn mahomes is really a good example on
uh sunday night football he had two
touchdowns where it was travis kelsey
running through the entire ravens
defense it was a decent throw he threw
it to him but this is kelsey as he's
running earning him passer rating points
and stuff right and uh byron pringle did
the same thing on a 40-yard run so the
other piece is if you make a bad throw
throw it right to a defender we're
giving you a big downgrade even if the
defender drops it and it's only over one
so it's just adding the context to each
play and in the qb's actual contribution
steve palazzolo he's the co-host of pro
football focus nfl podcast
did the media overreact to the first
week with aaron rodgers or did they
overact more so to the second week
performance against the lions
probably to the first week i mean
rogers has had games like that before
they just didn't happen to happen in
week one right it happened last year in
week six against the box it happened at
other times
every time he had a pff grade under 50
since 2016 which which he had in week
one it was terrible and under 50 is
pretty bad in our system every time he's
bounced back with four touchdowns
exactly four touchdowns and no
interceptions it's the fourth straight
time he's done it now so people could
have looked at history and said look
aaron rodgers has had bad games before
this happened to be in week one it
doesn't mean that jeopardy did it and
he'll probably bounce back he's facing
the lions and it was four touchdowns and
no interceptions and he played better so
i think aaron rodgers is gonna be okay
so relax again i i think we're going to
learn more about the packers and aaron
rodgers this week
than we did last week i
you're playing at home against the lines
so i was not surprised i was surprised
the lions were going toe-to-toe with
them in the first half uh i thought
there was a huge third down toss to
devontae adams in the third quarter that
it kind of propelled the the packers
there but
i'm i'm not surprised at all let's look
at rookie quarterbacks um is anybody
actually having a better season than we
think with these rookie quarterbacks
aside from mack jones
uh not really i mean i had high
expectations not not astronomical
expectations for trevor lawrence but
he's been disappointing so far he's got
the highest percentage of uncatchable
passes in the nfl this year by a pretty
significant margin he's not playing with
great timing what's uncatchable
just straight up an overthrow and
underthrow in front behind the receiver
doesn't have a catch a chance to holiday
you know there's those there's bang bang
catches there are opportunities but this
is he's just flat missing uh far more
than he should be um and then zach
wilson
all those interceptions against the
patriots not all his faults but his
mechanics are all over the place he's
fading away he's not stepping into
throws things he probably got away with
in college he's learning he can't um so
that hasn't been great so far and matt
jones has been the most efficient it's
he's been probably the safest as far as
game plan goes and throwing the
underneath stuff but his weak one game
against the dolphins was really
impressive uh plays under pressure his
accuracy so yeah mack jones i think has
been the clear guy he hasn't dominated
but not making as many mistakes as the
other guys
now you have justin fields coming in for
the bears
assess the bear's offensive line where
does that rank talent wise the the
tackles are playing okay right now as
far as pass protection goes uh they've
got jason peters at left tackle he's
almost 40 but he's still pretty good um
jermaine fetty's been okay as a pass
blocker at right tackle historically
he's not great there the interior's
gotten beat up so there's going to be
some pressure up front and the
quarterback
affects pressure rate because when when
a qb holds the ball it puts more
pressure on the offensive line even if
he's juking out of a sack so that's
what's going to be interesting to see
andy dalton generally gets the gets rid
of the ball faster than most
quarterbacks in the nfl he's top five
getting rid of it justin field so far
preseason in last week likes to hold it
let things develop scramble out a little
bit so there'll be a lot of pressure on
an offensive line that's definitely in
the you know bottom eight or ten uh i
think in the nfl right now do you guys
grade careers
like holy [ __ ] you do yeah is devin
hester a hall of famer now that's a
tricky one because special teams it's
its own
it's its own animal you know i i do
think you know when you're looking at
the hall of fame if there's if you've
completely changed the game daryl
patterson is going to have an
interesting argument that's hester-like
right i mean there is those guys were
game changers you you're afraid to kick
them the ball i think hester is i think
i think patterson probably is because
they were so good
at taking it to the house which is a
very rare thing wait you think
yeah he's the best kickoff returner of
all time in a time when that part of the
game is getting de-emphasized when you
you know kickers can just kick it
through the end zone and get a touch
back if they want and patterson still
extremely dangerous i mean the bucks
were you know dribbling at adam last
week because they were so afraid of him
he was an all-pro four times phillip
rivers hall of famer
the more i think about it i'm starting
to lean no on both phillip rivers and
eli manning you know just because i i
think the error thing matter you were
mentioned in error right how do you
compare
was there ever was philip rivers a top
five quarterback in his era yeah a
couple seasons he was but overall he's
top eight type of guy you're in the era
with with brady brees payton with aaron
rodgers uh with russell wilson big ben
it is tough to say this guy is an elite
player in his era so i'm starting to
lean the the playoffs are going to work
against rivers in this argument even
though the stats and generally he was
really good but i'm starting to lean no
i think for rivers
why no for eli
i mean he was an average slightly above
average nfl quarterback i say that with
a ton of respect that's a tough thing to
do
um who had the two super bowl runs i
think he'll get in i think people are
gonna buy into that
um but they also didn't make the
playoffs a lot and it was a very in
years where eli was a bottom third
quarterback right so
this there wasn't the continued sustain
sustained
success where he was a top eight guy
consistently he had a couple quick peaks
and there were nice peaks the giants
will take it but i just don't know if
you put that in the hall of fame yeah
but i go back to joe namath joe namath
won one game and you can say it might be
the most important game in nfl history
because it helped spring the merger
but he threw more interceptions than
touchdowns he had one unbelievable
moment but you know his defense was
brilliant that day they gave up seven
points to the colts in super bowl three
why is joe namath in the hall of fame
it's because people like the the feels
right with it's the feeling and it's a
tough for for someone like me that works
with with numbers so much because i
wanted to okay here's the whole body of
work um but i get it the hall of fame is
about moments and uh you know playoff
success and you know helmet catches and
things like that that eli has and look
the mario manningham cover two shot
against the patriots in 2011 is one of
the best throws in nfl history forget
the helmet thing that was kind of a jump
ball i mean that putting the ball on
manningham's hands wins the game for the
giants so i can talk myself into it but
but i generally lean toward the full
body of work am i watching the hall of
famer i don't i don't know if anybody
got that vibe when watching eli manning
always great to talk to you steve thanks
for joining us have a great weekend
thank you dan appreciate it steve
palazzolo he makes a smarter co-host to
pro football focus nfl podcast